une semaine pour préparer l'avenir
politique du mahdi initialement prévu
sur deux jours est annulé une première
fois la réunion va enfin pouvoir
commencer
et c'est dans la capitale du pays que
l'essentiel des discussions est appelé à
avoir lieu de façon prévu la première
consiste à se mettre d'accord sur les
objectifs de ces concertations en
présence des représentants de partis
politiques de la société civile des
groupes armés signataires de l'accord de
paix de 2015 et des syndicats deuxième
phase de jeudi à samedi prochain trouver
un terrain d'entente pour initier une
transition politique idéal cette fois en
présence des délégués nationaux
régionaux et de membres de la diaspora
une semaine de débats avec une volonté
ferme d'inclure toutes les parties mais
le sujet de crispation majeur semble
être celui de la durée de la transition
politique
pour le rmp l'ex majorité du président
déchu ib cas pas de position officielle
mais soumeylou boubèye maïga ex-premier
ministre du bk table sur un an voire un
an et demi avec un président et un
premier ministre civil pour moussa mara
lui aussi exprimé ministre l'ancienne
classe politique de se mettre en retrait
au profit des civils il faut que la
société civile soit mise en avant pour
que de nouveaux acteurs émergent pour
les parties initiateur de la
consultation populaire est mais cinq rfp
un an et demi à deux ans avec un
président civil serait souhaitable
les deux acteurs majeurs de la
transition
pour le changement attendu par le peuple
malien vous la mise sur pied d'un
nouveau mari sans le m5 rfp et le cnsp
sont en train de travailler pour
regrouper l'ensemble des forces vives de
la nation ou définir ensemble tout ce
qui concerne la transition
le format la durée et le doute
caractérisée de la transition
tous les acteurs qui participent au
débat ont la même préoccupation
s'assurer qu'il s'agit bien d'une
transition pour la jante et non d'une
confiscation du pouvoir
l'imam dicko figure majeure du mouvement
de la contestation avait mis en garde la
jambe sur ce point qui ont achevé la
révolution
mais je leur demande
[Musique]
après les concertations d'autres points
resteront à éclaircir
et alors que la jambe se targuer d'un
coup d'état sans heurt 15 blessés et 4
morts ont été dénombrés
une autre interrogation concerne la
libération de vendée tenue à bamako le
jour du coup d'état également une
enquête a été ouverte par la minus mans